so hello everyone and welcome to
academic jobs outside the u.s this is
the third and final webinar in our
three-part series on doing chinese
history in a new era this series is
organized by denise ho at yale
university and myself emily baum at uc
irvine we are very excited to be
broadcasting to you live from the same
location in southern california surprise
um and this webinar series has been
generously sponsored by the council on
east asian studies at yale university
and the long us china institute at uc
irvine we are also very grateful to our
long list of co-sponsors we will just
read their names out very quickly right
now they include harvard university's
fairbanks center the center for east
asian studies at stanford university the
project on china's global sharp power at
the huber institution the center for
asian research at york university the
department of history at simon fraser
university the institute of asian
research at the university of british
columbia the east asian studies program
at johns hopkins the east asian studies
program at uc santa cruz the global
china center at hong kong university of
science and technology and the hong kong
institute for the humanities and social
sciences at the university of hong kong
so just a couple of words about how this
session will be run before we get
started each presenter is going to speak
for about 10 to 12 minutes and at the
end of the session we will reconvene for
a moderated q a you should all know this
by now but if you have a question at any
point in the webinar please ask it using
the q a button at the bottom of your
screen in total this webinar will last
for approximately 75 minutes we are
recording it um and we will be recording
um only those panelists who have agreed
to be recorded but we will send out a
link to the youtube video in a follow-up
email to all registered participants so
be on the lookout for that if you can't
make it through the entire session
so we designed this webinar series with
the goal of supporting graduate students
and junior colleagues in the chinese
studies field last year one of our
webinars addressed the topic of careers
outside of academia and we'll drop that
link into the chat
and for that one panelists spoke about
jobs in government non-profits and
specialist books
based on the responses to last year's
series we decided to dedicate one
webinar this summer to the topic of
searching for jobs outside of the united
states in this session we are lucky to
be joined by four scholars of china
we'll talk about the characteristics of
the job market where they're currently
teaching what academic life is like at
their university and what challenges and
opportunities their academic systems
present
we hope that this panel will be of use
not only to scholars of china but also
to candidates on the job market in a
wide variety of disciplines
to save time we'll first introduce all
of our speakers briefly
our second speaker is tawo zhou
assistant professor in the school of
humanities at nanyang technological
university in singapore she is the
author of migration in the time of
revolution china indonesia and the cold
war out with cornell university press in
2019
our third speaker mayor brazelton is
university senior lecturer in global
studies of science technology and
medicine in the department of history
and philosophy of science at the
university of cambridge she is the
author of the book mass vaccination
citizens bodies and state power in
modern china published by cornell
university press in 2019.
finally charles chang is assistant
professor of environment and urban
studies at duke quinchon university he
specializes in computation and design
and his publications include articles in
the journal of chinese history political
analysis and landscape and urban
planning
hello everyone i'm jodhanwa i'm
assistant professor at nyon
technological university in singapore
um it's uh thank you emily and dennis
for organizing this event so i thought
it's still unsafe for many of us to
travel so i thought i'd give you a
virtual campus tour at
singapore so here you see the landmark
of the university of chinese heritage
center
so i start with
talking a little bit about my own
experience so
um i graduated from cornell in 2015 went
on the job market for two years i was
very fortunate to have job offers at the
end but the whole process
had been emotionally and physically very
training so very much according to what
rawana said about relevance
as emily mentioned my first book is
about china indonesia and the cold war
so i was kind of in this in between
place between the fields of modern china
and modern southeast asia
although we have seen the transnational
term for more than a decade most of the
jobs unfortunately in many parts of the
world are still geared towards regional
countries
country specific research so somehow in
singapore because of
its geographical location its economic
and strategy needs
i was encouraged um to kind of cross
over between china and southeast asia so
singapore has been my intellectual home
for six years one year as a postdoc and
five years as a system professor
uh so
for those of you who are not familiar
with singapore i'm just going to briefly
run through the academic institutions so
there are six
major universities and uh higher
education institutions across the island
state
uh the national university singapore
many of you probably have heard about is
the flagship has the most
long-standing prestigious programs in
humanities and social sciences and of
course my own home institute and tu will
always try to challenge that
um unus college is physically on the u.s
campus but it's autonomous independent
liberal arts college
and then the smu is more like a business
school it's located downtown right
absent city
i'm going to talk about them later these
are two new universities rapidly
expanding their humanities programs
so if you've never been to singapore
would you pursue an academic career here
um so first thing is that the economic
academic system here is modeled on the
united states what does it mean it means
that basically the drop application
process is similar right so now it's set
standard drop talk 45 minutes it's a
interview with the search committee
which could be either all people of your
field or kind of in my case there were
historians and also social scientists
and the 10-year application process is
also similar
but the major difference between
singaporean universities and american
universities that
most of the institutions here especially
the humanities programs are very young
they're kind of up and coming so what
does it mean for junior scholars like us
i think it means like it's very bottom
heavy so when i join my department there
were only one or two associate professor
and only one food professor so we're we
lost that food professor and we're still
doing a search for senior faculty in
asian history broadly defined so it
means that you don't have
many mentors could who could set your
paws you need to forge your own past but
the upside of that is that you have like
a group of really brilliant dynamic uh
young colleague
and i really enjoy brainstorming with my
colleagues in the department
and it also means that basically you
even got opportunity as a junior faculty
to create your own program i think this
is quite unique in singapore because the
humanities views are growing very
rapidly
so um i'm going to talk a little bit
about the job opportunities available
here so first you see the campus of um
as i'm using over management university
as uss these two institutes are probably
not that well known outside of singapore
but they are growing very very fast they
want to recruit international talents
very rapidly so how would they do that
they will offer really attractive
payments
so for example later on you see a job
advertisement for education track
faculty position
uh just keep in mind that that is
substantially different from the adjunct
positions
in the united states in the sense that
um duringly the salary is
internationally compatible it's
definitely economically
viable you live
economically stable life in singapore so
i think on that uh the singapore system
is a lot better
um and also uh you might also see
advertisement
for post-doctoral fellowships at our
asia research institute it's also part
of the national university of singapore
that's kind of semi-autonomous
um these kind of positions usually start
with a two or three year contract
however i've seen many colleagues who
kind of smoothly transition
from say a short-term post-doctoral
fellowship to a long-term research
position so you won't be teaching but
but it's kind of like a 10-year track
research research-focused position which
is also economically viable and stable
um so now i'm going to advertise for my
own university so here you see our
signature building the hive
it's also nicknamed uh the densum
building
uh so ntu is located at the far west end
of singapore we're almost in malaysia
um so some of you might think that
advertisement for this night young
assistant professorship um it's a really
really generous package uh coming with
one million singapore dollar research
ground you can still apply to it uh the
deadline is september 30th 2021 so this
position has been geared more towards uh
engineering and science
natural sciences however uh recently we
see a very encouraging sign in the sense
that my colleague florence mock
his daughter of co-work hong kong got
this position so we are very hopeful
that uh probably university are going to
channel more of the funding towards
humanities
um there is also the presidential
postdoc fellowship so the call is
currently closed but very open again in
january next year um it's a two-year
contract also coming with a very
generous salary research ground and i
think there is also relocation ground as
well
um so yeah
would you would you move here if you've
never been to singapore how is it really
like working here so i already talked
about the advantages of size so some of
the issues uh from what i heard from
providence seems like singapore system
is quite similar to the hong kong system
in the sense that um this is uh my
university in particular is a very tech
and science-happy university right so as
scholar of humanity you are constantly
asked to prove that your research is
valuable right so this kind of anxiety
led to certain inflexibility in terms of
your publishing outlets um basically my
department meticulously rank all the
journals into tier one tier one a and
tier one b
and i have to like send screenshots of
my google scholar citation report um
like for my annual evaluation so in
other words um when i talked to my
colleagues i found that it's kind of
similar to the uk and australia system
but that's something i never heard about
when i was going through my phd training
in the united states
um similar to hong kong there are plenty
of funding opportunities around um
however
in terms of how to use the grounds the
faculty members had less autonomy so
basically you have to meticulously
um
meticulous budget itemize um everything
at all your grounds and then when you
when you're going to use it you have to
show meticulous documentation when you
are seeking reimbursement so the
paperwork is a bit daunting and that's i
think that is also
very energy-sucking and tough it's it's
a big time sucker so that kind of
prohibits many of my colleagues from
applying for research grants
um but having said that
i would still say that singapore is a
great great place for scholars like
myself right who study chinese migration
and also because uh singapore's location
there are lots of greek scholars um
uh southeast asia and south asia so that
means it's also a great a great place
for those who study intra-asian
connections right china southeast asia
relations migration china south asia
relations and migration
and uh ramona talked about the
linguistic environment in hong kong
similar in singapore singapore is a
multilingual society right so mandarin
malay and taimir are all used so what
does it mean for a china scholar means
that basically you have a wider um kind
of body of colleagues that you can work
with for example at ngu at the u.s there
are chinese departments right it's an
interdisciplinary program with scholars
of literature
of course of like uh science and
technology studies and also of history
for example in ntu history uh in india
chinese department we have medical
histories from xiaoping who also wrote
about cholera
someone you can you can work with and
also it means that you have more kind of
students who have the capacity to work
on chinese sources right so it's easier
in my case easier to recruit research
assistant who can help me process data
in chinese
and in terms of access to data in
mainland china i would say that um
basically oh i think two minutes yeah
i've tried to wrap it up
in terms of research your data uh in
mainland china i think in the past field
work is relatively easy so basically
it's easy to travel back and forth uh
and also i feel like because the because
the political relationship between
singapore and china are more
amicable my informants are more relaxed
when i or less guarded when i tell them
i'm a scholar based in singapore after
covet i i'm still trying to carry out uh
research through online book purchases
such as from confusion or collection
data through my local partners i think
international visibility is the biggest
challenge because in the past you have
to do long-haul flights attend aha or
aas but after kobe thinks lots of the
events are moving to uh zoom out or
worship platform i feel like there are
more opportunities for international
collaboration so that's the end of my
presentation i look forward to comments
and questions and i'll be happy to talk
about for example how to balance life
and work uh in a place like singapore
thank you
okay
so
as denise mentioned my name is mary
brazelton i'm a senior lecturer in the
department of history and philosophy of
science at the university of cambridge
and
if you're attending this session i'm
guessing that you're
applying for a
postdoc or possibly a permanent academic
position in the uk these comments will
be focused more on the latter um simply
because that's my experience so what
it's like to go through the process of
applying for it and then taking up a
lectureship
in the uk
and i'll start by actually talking
rather a lot about logistics uh before i
move on to talking about the academic
life and its challenges and benefits
simply because i approach this thinking
about what i would have liked to know
when i was at the point of making
applications like this
so
the first thing to note is
what a different
structure of uh academic life
uh exists in academic careers so
tawa mentioned that singapore's
educational system is modeled on the u.s
that's not so much the case for the uk
and there's an entirely different
vocabulary of
job applications as a result so a
lecturer for example the starting point
of a job is an assistant professor in
the u.s in the uk
um it's a lecturer in the uk
traditionally the title of professor was
a senior title that you only received
after a career a lifetime of publishing
um
and and working in in scholarship so
there are useful differences of
nomenclature to be aware of there's also
i think a pretty fundamental difference
in terms of the permanent nature of
lectureships in the uk as opposed to
tenure track positions in the u.s in the
uk
job security is more
disconnected from promotion and
advancement so a lectureship that is
permanent has good job security
generally speaking um
but in uh but promotion is not
guaranteed you have to apply for
promotion
um sort of going through a round a
series of
um of
applications uh that is different in
nature than the tenure system in the u.s
so i got my position in
uh 2015 and since then i've sat on
several search committees so this is
really informed for me by by time on
both sides of that particular table
one thing to know about applications is
that the timeline
for
applying for and receiving an academic
job in the uk works very differently
often there's a much shorter period
between jobs being announced and the
interviews being held it's not
necessarily conforming to the academic
calendar that we're familiar with
another difference that i found really
fascinating was the fact that in the uk
the norm is that you have all job talks
on the same day
and i was actually able to attend all
the other job talks for the same
position that we were all applying for
um in the us it's quite common to be
expected to go out to dinner with the
people who are interviewing you in the
uk we were told as job applicants and
candidates for the same job to go and
have dinner together without anyone from
the department along so a very different
approach i think to sociability
um in that context of job applications
the job talk was also very short it was
15 minutes
and it was not as important as the
formal interview so the whole process
was held over two days and the formal
interview on day two was
a much more kind of formal panel
along with that there are significant
legal restrictions on what can be asked
in those formal interviews in front of a
panel
most of the questions in that interview
were
i would say pretty similar to what you
might get in
interviews for a north american job in
academia
one crucial difference though i think is
that demonstrating your ability to get
external grant funding is more important
and that's because of a particular
difference between
north america and the uk in terms of
getting funding both for your research
and for your postgraduate students
so in the uk postgraduate students who
are working towards phds are often
supported by external grants
so not university funding
but fellowships or projects likewise the
research that academics do is often
supported by grants that they have
applied for that can be
several years in duration
and can run into the millions of pounds
or euros in value
and so often at the point of application
it's really good to know that that is
part of the system that in many cases as
an academic in the uk you will be
expected to apply for and receive
extensive funding from a variety of
agencies some of which i've put on the
slide
and this is in part because there aren't
necessarily always a lot of research
funds available to universities um and
so career advancement in many cases is
tied to your ability to
think uh in a way that will
be conducive to getting really big uh
scale uh funding and grants that will
support not just your work but postdocs
and phd students um for for years
now if you get to the point of
negotiating a position and preparing to
to actually come to the uk
i think it's probably worth knowing that
there are some key differences between
north america and the uk system in terms
of what's possible to negotiate and
what's desirable
as a new um
starter and a position here to negotiate
um so
it may be quite difficult to negotiate
on base things like salaries but there
are other things that are quite
important to consider
notably i would call attention to visa
fees
i think i've missed a slide here but
that's fine
in my experience relocation packages are
really generous but in some cases you
have to pay for your own visa
which can amount to thousands of dollars
or pounds so if you're offered a job and
you can negotiate
ask whether the department will cover
those fees just to give you a sense i
ran the numbers and i found that
to go from receiving a job and starting
a work visa to
um
to the final point of getting permanent
residency and even citizenship in the uk
that total amount is about eight
thousand to nine thousand uh pounds so
about ten thousand us dollars so it's
something that if you can get your
university to pay for it and some
universities will do this that would be
extremely um desirable
um also
there are other aspects of logistics
that i'd be happy to talk about in the q
a but i have a timer and i see that i'm
quickly running out of time so i'd like
to transition to talk a bit more about
some of the less tangible aspects of
jobs in the uk
so first just some interesting
differences of academic life
it was really fascinating to move to the
uk and realize that certain concepts in
conceptual frameworks could be very very
different so in the uk empire matters
hugely as a category of historical
analysis
and in some respects
studies of non-western regions or
histories can be assumed or even just
read as studies of empire and especially
of british empire
this has been interesting to navigate as
a historian of china especially as
british universities embrace projects of
decolonization
and that's something i'm happy to speak
about a bit more if there's time this
kind of idea of decolonizing the
curriculum but one of the points that i
do find myself making over and over in
my teaching is that britain wasn't the
only empire of the world and that
empires aren't only ever western anyway
um
that it may be worth noting um but given
that what non-western history is read
often as imperial history area studies
can work a little bit differently as a
result so often
i'm surprised to find that people
in the uk think of china as part of
southeast asia
instead of east asia coming from north
america where you have those interesting
regional boundaries that can be
interesting to to explore um even though
of course these categories are
themselves historically contingent in
all kinds of ways
but in general i think you see ideas of
asia being tied much more strongly to
south asia
in really fascinating ways and again i'm
happy to talk about that more in the q a
other points to note
um
ta'amu had mentioned
the points about
things like
evaluations of your research and
teaching
being tied to certain kinds of
publications and metrics
that connects to something in the uk
called the research excellence framework
the metrication uh the ways in which
your publications are evaluated by your
peers often
and regulating this happens every five
years the ref i'm at cambridge and
cambridge and oxford are two
universities in the uk that i would say
try to
protect their academics from the ref in
all kinds of useful ways but it is
something that's important to know about
um if you are applying for a job because
it is something that
um you're
expected to publish a certain number of
papers
for each ref evaluation and so that
often becomes part of planning um
so i don't want to go on for too long i
want to mention very briefly some
challenges and some positive aspects
um
but i will note as well that there are
well i'll start with a positive which is
that
um
there's just briefly the um the costing
that i ran up uh so coming to 9 000
pounds for a full visa and permanent
residency um
so one of the wonderful things about
life in the uk is the particular kind of
academic sociability
it's a really intense and wonderful
approach to academic life i think in all
kinds of ways and again i'm happy to
talk about that a bit more in the in the
q a
um but that said there are challenges
life in the uk in all kinds of ways can
take a lot to adjust to
the weather takes a lot to adjust to the
very very short daylight hours in the
winter take a lot to adjust to you
as an american working on chinese
history in the uk that effectively means
that life is split between three
continents and that is something that
others might find as well your research
and
the focus of your study is in uh is in
east asia
in china
your family perhaps is in north america
and
your job and your life are in europe so
it can be
complicated by things like the outbreak
of a global pandemic
there are cultural differences that
people can sometimes laugh about like
the
um you know the differences in
terminology but i've been really struck
by the ways in which uh you can have a
conversation with someone in the context
of british academia and as you can see
from this graphic that i've depicted
what you think is happening might
actually come across totally differently
to
somebody in in the british system
um
i think i'm keenly aware that i'm
running out of my allotted 12 minutes
so i just want to note that there are
particular challenges at the moment in
the uk
um i never thought um when i came to
the to britain that i would be in a
position to strike um and to join a
union and participate in an industrial
action
uh but in
2017
and or 2018 and then again last year
that is what i found myself doing as
part of the universities and colleges
union
particularly as
part of a pushback across the sector
um uh against issues with pensions for
uk university staff
um and so that that dispute is still
ongoing but as with many other places
the working conditions of teaching staff
in the uk
are under constant pressure from
corporatizing interests and so that too
has been a feature not just of my life
as an employee of a university but also
as a teacher in talking through these
issues with my students in really
fascinating way
so
the thing that i will end on is simply
to note that one of the really lovely
benefits of my time in the uk has been
exploring a really rich rich world of of
sources i'm so fortunate to be at
cambridge where the anita research
institute is located um with a variety
of uh really great archives in
particular for history of science and
medicine in china
but there are so many more
um sources that i wouldn't have
necessarily been so aware of if i hadn't
been
at cambridge
where there are so many valuable aspects
of things like the national archives the
foreign office archives
that shed light on chinese history
especially in the 20th century in really
fascinating ways so i will stop there
but thanks very much for your time
all right um
this is my turn oh let me share my
screen
all right uh hi everyone i'm chuck chung
i'm uh to do collision university or
dku i think you've learned a lot from
our other panelists
which show the institutions in asia and
europe in general
um
and i think it will be helpful if i can
briefly introduce my university which is
a university in china
and
and which might be quite different from
other universities
um so um our university is a kind of
like it's a liberal arts university in
china
that is to say it's very different from
the chinese universities in that it's
com it's completely modeled after
american institutions namely duke
um it's very small and competitive and
it's research oriented um generally it's
a it's a joint venture university on set
up by
duke university and
the high
university
and
it is located in queensland on
um
some new that's where
queensland is kind of like a small
country level city
it it
it has been the richest county in china
for the past 15 years
um
so quinceanera has a lot of advanced
manufacturing uh industry and the uh the
local government think that it would be
a great idea to promote higher education
in a sense so um as at the new
university we we uh we enjoyed a
generous
support from the the local government
um
so what is what's his details mission um
to do concern universities like i said
it's a liberal arts uh university um our
mission is to introduce a world-class
liberal arts education to china and we
want to educate classes of internet
international talents
um so that is very different from a
traditional you know chinese university
that is research based it's very similar
to the liberal arts colleges in the
united states we want to
we also want to promote the innovation
of higher education and i and the
support height
caliber research and academic excellence
and i will talk a little bit about that
in terms of the differences from the dku
and the uh the american liberal arts
colleges
so in terms of his size we we are quite
small we have uh 14 undergraduate
majors
five masters program we have current 130
faculties this is uh in the year of 2019
um and you know almost 900 undergraduate
students were still expanding
we want to keep the the faculty and
student ratio to one to six or one to
seven and potentially we will have about
two thousand undergraduate students
which means that we will probably still
uh recruit a fair fairly large number of
uh full-time tenure-track faculty
um
like i said our core mission is a
liberal arts education so we want to
educate you our undergraduate students
to have a proposal
live life
rooted globally
the meaning that we have we are uh 60
percent of students come from them all
over the world um
so we want to cultivate
an international culture where
students can learn from one another and
the the undergrad liberal education is a
core meaning that we as a full-time
faculty we do not
get pressure to you know pursue academic
funding in china
or
um publish certain journals by some kind
of metrics you know in a way we are
encouraged to do research but it's not
uh mandatory for your tenure case
and
in terms of the undergraduate education
we have a bit different structure we
have couple features that are different
from a lot of uh universities in the u.s
in that we have
an intensive seven-week term
so
in total we have we we have four terms
per academic year but each term is only
seven weeks long and for undergraduate
students they normally just take two
courses
and
and learn all these kind of things in
seven weeks and in instead of the
department structure we have the
divisional area of knowledge so we only
have three big divisions the divisions
of arts and humanities divisions of
social science and division
division of natural and applied science
so that is because we want to encourage
interdisciplinary studies um so that we
do not want to silence faculty in just
one
division
so for the the undergrad
undergraduate education the students
were asked to take the common core
courses
um which is
which includes uh for example the
chinese a little bit of chinese history
and and and the culture and for example
the
the the the philosophical thinking
and etc etc so in that case the student
would who's uh educated in a chinese
system would know more of the western
ideas and philosophy
as well as china's place in the world
and then they also take language courses
for chinese students they have to take
english
courses to improve their english and
then they were asked to take um
divisional courses and introduce
interdisciplinary courses and also the
the undergrad students
normally spend one year one year on in
uh
abroad in a university either in the u.s
or
or other parts of the world uh most of
them went to duke because um that is a
easy way for them to to to to uh get
this kind of credit
uh exchanged and
and then in the fourth year they
returned to uh dku to continue and
finish their study um because we're so
new so we actually do not have any uh
uh undergraduate students who have
graduated yet on this coming year will
be the the first cohort of our
uh students
um so that is the the the uh
teaching and the education part of the
dku
uh
uh i also want to give you an idea about
the
about the
the campus
so um currently we are literally
building our our university we uh we are
going to build like uh in on five phases
of the of the campus which in total
gonna be about 200 acres of of land
but currently we have the phase one
complete cut completed um
so we only have couple uh buildings but
they are all designed by um
a
company that's started that and the
buildings are certified by lee uh
lead green campus so that means uh we
are breathing uh
kind of like high quality air
that is comparable to los angeles
perhaps
and we are uh we are expanding to the
phase two so this year
um
the phase two of the campus will be
complete and uh uh
in the phase two we will have libraries
um
uh
gymnasium and as well as faculty and
student apartments so in a way um
dq's uh gonna be much nicer in this
coming year
um okay so in the end i wanna talk a
little bit about this hiring process
which you might be very interested in um
so the hiring process at dku is not very
very different from the hiring process
in a
in the
american universities in that we have
three rounds of the interview the first
round is just like
um
it's conducted remotely it's just like
any universities in the u.s the second
round is the interview with tqu's
leadership
you'll be asked to talk about on your
your research faith into this uh dku's
interdisciplinary environment and how
you see your yourself
in teaching in terms of the curriculum
at dku the third round is quite
different from what you get in the u.s
in that um we would invite the
potential candidates for campus visit
during the winter break
but
but because normally every year for
these years we we are hiring on 20 to 30
on tenure track faculty since we're
expanding so we would invite
all the candidates uh to the campus in
the same time and this process is not to
create a competitive environment
uh between candidates um because
potentially if you are like struck you
are strong candidates dq can potentially
hire all of them right all of you so so
in a way this process is
rather trying to observe everyone in
terms of how well you you would work
with existing faculty at dku and and how
you can uh handle for example teamwork
so this this on campus visit will take
about two days where you will give a 15
minutes job talk and
in the you also will will will
um form on a team to to create
a of a sort of a imaginative major and
explain why you want to do that that is
a bit different from the interview
process in the united states and once
you get hired dq offers a competitive um
salary
um
[Music]
and the and the startup fund and and the
generous uh benefits comparable to the
us institutions the typical teaching
load
um
is uh
the typical teaching load is five
courses um per academic year um however
currently we are
under four teaching uh four courses per
academic year and the teaching's a bit
flexible so in that case
you could arrange on your teaching
uh into two semesters um that are most
convenient for you and spend some time
in it
for your own research
um
and lastly um
okay so lastly i want to see that uh in
terms of applying to the jobs at dku on
sometimes on
uh people don't realize that that um
that
unlike the application in the u.s
uh where you have to be very clear fate
to position sometimes um
uh because dtu is expanding so dq is
willing to to uh to be a little bit
flexible in terms of the
job applications so if you're a strong
candidate and you you see a position
that is related to you however may not
be
extremely related you still should apply
because in a way maybe dq could uh fit
you into another position that
that
that they are trying to expand to so in
a way um there's possibility that if if
um the
position that you're applying is not
not completely a clear fate to you um
um the last i want to mention that i
really enjoy teaching at dku um
strangely because here the students are
highly vote
motivated and they are eager to learn um
even you know in the field of humanities
people are very students are very
interested
also the staff is highly motivated i've
never uh received email reply more than
24 hours
at dku
all the staff try to be very helpful um
and in the end um also
my colleagues are very young as well and
i very much enjoy
the environment where everybody is
trying to build their academic career of
course um we have a many problems
especially during this covet pandemic as
a young university however i i think the
academic environment is very encouraging
and at least
i enjoy this young and invigorating
environment
thank you
thank you so much to all of our
panelists i deeply enjoyed all of your
uh
all of your presentations um and uh
recruiting style as well um
i have
we have some questions in the q a and in
the chat if you did ask a question in
the chat please go ahead and move it to
q a since we'll focus on those
um we'll start with a few questions that
address all the panelists and then we'll
go to questions that
focus on particular
individuals
so a first question from our audience
is a two-part question for everyone
why did you apply for jobs outside of
the u.s and does your future plan
involve returning to the us in an
academic capacity
well i couldn't get started so i when i
graduated i applied everywhere um so i
landed in singapore large because that
was the only offer i received and
i think one of the reasons i didn't get
to talk about it but i think singapore
asia in general is a good environment
for working mothers especially academics
with small children in the sense that
child care is less expensive and it's
affordable to hire
helpers or nannies so i do find that's
a big attraction for me another thing i
think it's that close to family because
i was born raised
in china my parents and now shenzhen is
only four hours flight away
um so
yeah so for me i think
it's
wetter going my fa my friends always ask
me are you planning to go back to the us
in my case probably for family reason
not in the foreseeable future
i'd be happy to hear what the other
colleagues
yeah i can go next um
so um when i apply my uh apply positions
i also applied it and everywhere um i
got 16 um job interviews in the united
states um for tenure track positions
um i have on two job offers in the end
but i choose dku um
i think i got some difficulties in the
us because my background is a bit
interdisciplinary
and normally in the u.s the difficulty
is that if you're interdisciplinary you
have to try really hard to fade into a
department uh
environment which um it's very difficult
for me so in the in the end i feel that
a lot of positions in the u.s
um are not were not a good faith for me
and also um
i spent a lot of most i pretty much most
of my academic career in the united
states and the uh
uh
last year when i applied jobs at dku i
feel like because i studied china and i
spent too much time in the us i feel my
research is a bit out of touch
you know in a way that i do need to do
some kind of field work to get to know
the situation on the ground so i decided
to move back to
to to to china um
um um i have families back in wisconsin
united states so i do visit my family as
to the future i i don't know i think it
all depends on
on my research if i think it's
a good idea to move on then i i will but
so far i've been having a good time in
china and
i'm happy not to move
so maybe i can go next quickly um
and just say why i
decided to apply like everyone else i
applied everywhere
um
and i was really really lucky and that
basically my dream job and my dream in
the best department that i could hope
for came up the year that i was applying
and i got really really lucky
um and i am someone who trained in a
history of science program and so for me
to be able to get a job in a department
of history and philosophy of science was
i the the chances of that were
vanishingly rare so for me to be able to
continue to work in an academic
community that was organized around
that field of the history of science was
really really precious
um and so for me that was absolutely why
you know it was barely a decision to
have to make to apply
um and then
yeah so that's really my answer is that
it that was what i would have
the best i could have really hoped for i
think um
yeah
thank you all for those responses we
have a question from kehan nahad
who says thank you for this very
informative panel how can scholars
studying topics outside the bounds of
east asian and southeast asian studies
position themselves competitively for
employment um in in these regions
or maybe uh how about for employment at
your institution
okay i can get started since invention
southeast asia so for singapore uh
singapore has been a very cosmopolitan
place but i think after pandemic we see
similar trends all around the world is
currently becoming more insular so
that tendency also affects how you
position yourself while applying for
jobs in singapore so for south
certainness and south um i think it's
generally singapore is generally very
friendly to southeast asian is because
um south east asia is strategically
important to singapore how you can
tailor your project
for example if you could effectively
tailor your project to
some of the governmental agendas in
singapore meaning for example smart
cities
uh urban development uh science and
technology intra intra asia regional
connectivity i think these are the key
words so for example my uh i mentioned
earlier my colleague florence mock who
recently got this night assistant
professorship i think she's very savvy
in framing her project not just as about
hong kong it's about decolonization and
also about urban development in the
global cities of asia so definitely like
cater it more
towards some of the official general in
singapore it's very important not just
for uh job application but also for
ground application as well
um i can go next um
so um
at dku i i don't think um starting some
something outside of asia is not is a
problem because we sometimes
intentionally hire um faculty who
who teaches
um
areas outside of asia for example we
have um faculty who teach american
politics um and that that is appealing
part because um we we try to um promote
international higher education and our
students are very interested in
on knowledges something like you know
even
judaism or even you know um
european history so so in a way it's not
a disadvantage if you study something on
that is not based in asia
maybe i can
follow the the same order um
as the previous question so just for the
part of the uk to be honest i think my
advice on this question
um would be to just pay very close
attention to the department or faculty
that is advertising the job which i
realize is quite general advice but i
think
it's particularly applicable in a case
like cambridge or other uk universities
where the institutional configurations
can be very unique so for example at
cambridge
the history faculty up until recently
had one person working on southeast asia
who uh connected to various aspects of
overseas chinese communities
um
rachel leo whose work i'm sure i'm
underselling in all kinds of ways
but
most of the teaching in
what we would consider asian history was
happening in the faculty of asian and
middle eastern studies so a totally
different faculty and i think possibly
even a separate school within the
university um and there wasn't any kind
of in my position was created de novo
new
um in history and philosophy of science
so
um it really i think is probably just a
lesson to think carefully about the
department that's advertising the
position
and how your work would fit into the
existing faculties
research interests and themes
really as much as anything so
thank you we actually have two questions
about where you find job announcements
outside of the us so i wonder if we
could go around and just um in a quick
list uh name the top sites where you
found postings um about either your
positions or international positions
so i think we all check the each with
each net i i've been away from the job
market for a while so i'm not familiar
right h nat um and um but i i agree like
some of the universities outside the us
are not very close to someone's posting
all their jobs um on these platforms so
i'd be happy to stand the links to the
two positions i talked about
at my home institution and another thing
i recently thought very useful is
academic twitter so lots of job posts i
i got notified on twitter um in person
yes um i i
i i did this same thing i i i look at
jobs um at h-net and uh
uh i also joined a lot of many lists as
well as looking through this uh job
posting at different kind of uh um
associations website
um also i i just use google a lot
actually there's a lot of jobs
if you just search your field
and then tenure check on google and that
would pop up a lot of information so so
i look at that as well
so there's one website for uk academic
jobs where i think all of them are
posted which is jobs.ac.uk
and that gives you a smorgasbord of
different options and you can filter it
as as needed but that's what i would
normally direct
people to uh for looking at uk positions
thank you so much for this i see that
we're almost out of time
i was thinking that perhaps we could ask
uh one teaching and one research
question that um
any one of you can respond to if you
like it doesn't have to be everyone um
but uh we have a question from joshua
tan what are some of the challenges and
opportunities regarding teaching or
course design for non-us contexts
in other words
are the
the
syllabi that you've designed in the u.s
are they relevant and how did you adapt
yours
i think being in asia allow you to teach
more niche topics because the students
have
they really have a good background
knowledge about a region in their
pre-universal clinical education for
example i teach topics such as modern
indonesia world war ii in south east
asia these probably probably are not
really pragmatic in the western context
but um in terms of the general
curriculum such as introduction to asia
pacific i found it really interesting to
reframe some of the debates and topics
in the asia
context in the sense that you don't
you know what we teach what research are
usually framed by the political
discourse
or the larger political context where
we're situated so it's it's kind of fun
to to rework on these frameworks and
reshape the for example discussion
question or debate topics but i think
the general like in the question like
what you
read or work on during
during your qualification exam that's
still very useful um but
you probably need to frame it in a
different way
thank you does anybody else want to
chime in on teaching
i was just going to briefly say that
teaching at
cambridge and more generally in the
oxbridge system is so weird and unusual
that i had to learn a whole new
vocabulary
where you know students aren't in years
they're in part two or part three
um and i think for me the biggest change
was giving many fewer lectures
and therefore having to squeeze and
compress a lot more material very
quickly
especially because the very specialized
nature of the uk educational system
means that
students only study a few topics in
depth before going to university and so
they have a lot of really intense
knowledge about several topics but not
necessarily
a breadth of knowledge not necessarily
very much knowledge at all about um asia
or asian history in particular so it can
be that can be a challenge but also
really fascinating and rewarding in
different ways
thank you so much
i think for me it's um
because china and the u.s are so
different so sometimes my students do
not know certain things that have that
have been censored by the chinese
government so in my class i would i
would actually teach them you know um i
would i would mention things like chem
and square event and
um among other things and i would
encourage my students to use google
in
instead
instead of baidu if you can imagine that
they're in channel um other than that
actually i've found that students are
really interesting once they started to
learn this kind of stuff they feel very
i guess inspired and they tend to ask me
a lot of questions about you know things
that we taught in you know either in
chinese history or your or you know you
know western philosophy something like
that and uh that part is uh it's a great
rewarding experience for me
thank you so much for sharing those
experiences let's ask a final research
question that i will tag on a couple of
the individual questions um so an
anonymous attendee asks about um human
subjects research infrastructure
protocol in your institution for example
if you use ethnographic methods um so
that's a question director for the whole
panel
i
i i think doing research in china is
great because in a way um you you can do
your field work all the time by just
talking to people and trying different
kind of things um
on the uh recent crackdown on academia
does not really affect us much um
frankly um
when we designed dku i i learned that we
we
we pretty much want to protect academic
freedom at dku meaning that you teach
whatever you like to teach
and uh in the end dq will defend you if
um if that is saying as problematic by
the chinese government but but of course
uh we are speaking outside of
on you will have to take a personal risk
in terms of what you you say and what
you do um but but
my experience is that um i do research
on religion and uh and for example
earlier this year i visited koshkar and
uh
and et cetera et cetera and i don't find
i i didn't find it uh problematic at all
so in a way and i mean if you um learn
those kind of things over time you would
understand a little bit better about the
boundaries there
um
in terms of on
the kind of like a
research environment
in regards to the irb we are trying to
um
innovate irb a little bit we try to keep
the irb as rigorous just like in the u.s
institutions just because we have to
protect human subjects
in general especially in china but we
also want to innovate a bit in case you
do something with regard to for example
social media because uh
you know
the american system did not probably
have much enough about irb regarding
social media as well so oh
if you if you do something related to
social media and computation on at dku
you will get
probably a speedier irp process compared
to that same process in the united
states just because we had some new
innovations regarding that
okay well we have gone over time so um i
think i'm going to wrap this up but once
again i would like to thank all of our
wonderful panelists for their super
informative and very interesting talks
um we'd like to thank the council on
east asian studies especially stephanie
kim and richard sosa for providing all
the staffing and support for this event
and of course we would like to thank all
of you for tuning in so thank you to all
of our supporters for making this summer
webinar series a huge success um all the
best for the rest of your summers and
hopefully we will see you again next
year so take care everyone